I mean like the ideas of the West like
I've heard I've just gotten like I get
messages from people like from all over
and like in places like India I've heard
feminism is spreading there like I've
heard that do you not find that to be
true
so firstly the West has no value the
only thing the West seems to defend
fervently is LGBT I'm not saying
anything bad about it I'm not I'm just
saying it's the only thing that they'll
stand up and fight for I don't know why
it's weird like they don't care about
anything else they don't care about
children going without child support
they don't care about people dying in
Wars they don't care about our old our
parents being in parent and homes they
don't care about crime they don't care
about they'll be able to pay their
energy bills they don't care about
nothing but they give a [ __ ] some for
some reason about this one thing and
they'll [ __ ] throw the flag all
around them surrounded around six that's
that's all they care about it's [ __ ]
strange so that's the first thing about
the values of the West second thing the
harder society and the harder the life
is as a whole the longer it's going to
take for feminism to spread feminism
only exists in a vacuum of an easy life
if you're living in a society like India
where life is hard feminism disappears
because the harder life is the closer
people naturally revert to their gender
roles if you've got a bunch of 10 men 10
women stranded them on a desert island
and they had to survive very quickly the
men would do men's [ __ ] and the women
would do women [ __ ] there'd be very
little talk about feminism and equality
and all this [ __ ] would [ __ ] vanish
when [ __ ] hits the fan right so in
countries where life is harder feminism
can't take hold because feminism can
only exist in a vacuum of a very
privileged life I'm sure there's some
kid in India who didn't get laid off
some chick and he's complaining she's a
feminist there's a bunch of dumb [ __ ]
right but but I think the world is going
to get a lot harder I think the world is
cyclical I think it's been easy for a
while I think hard times are coming and
when hard times come people are going to
naturally revert to what gives them the
highest chance of survival which is
gender roles right I have the best
chance of survival being a man and a
woman has the best chance of survival
being my woman that's how she's going to
function do you think women typically
are happier
um as Housewives rather than a career
well depends on the career no it depends
on the man the answer is absolutely not
really yes because giving life is the
most beautiful thing a female can do
that's what you've evolved to do that's
the thing that men cannot do I think
that women who focus on having children
and do their best to be good mothers in
the end are the happiest females on the
planet being a mother and being a
housewife is kind of different though
okay no but it's it's essentially the
same thing if you're a housewife long
enough I'm going to assume you're going
to end up having children and I think
that the sooner a woman has children the
better if she can find a good man and
have a child that's a fantastic thing I
think it's a beautiful thing and I don't
see the point in a woman slaving away
for a corporation that doesn't care
about her as opposed to slaving away for
her own flesh and blood I think that's a
complete waste of a life I think if men
are already doing that why would you
want to go along and do that because the
story is not just living away for
cooperation a career can involve a
million different things well that's
exactly what a career is it's slaving
away for a corporation that doesn't care
about you and I understand you have to
pay the bills and I understand you don't
want to be completely sufficient you
want to be self-sufficient you want to
be dependent on a man I understand all
that but an idealistic scenario in the
vacuum of ideology if you could sit and
have and be a woman and focus on having
children or focus on doing a job I think
on a long enough time scale you're gonna
be much happier with your progeny as
opposed to working a job can I ask you a
question because I feel like we talk a
lot about hoes we talk about a lot of
the extreme there's a lot of great
matter in the middle sure where a lot of
women kind of get lost for example
I think that one of the issues sometimes
that I hear a lot about and I personally
may say I feel it sometimes is that when
you're also a quite educated woman
intellectual intelligent whatever smart
a lot of the time naturally you speak in
a way that stands out from other people
right and I find that a lot of the time
that kind of intimidates some of the
mandem where they start thinking this
girl is a bit too much now it is not my
fault that I'm smart it's not my fault I
can put one and one together very nicely
very quickly
give me a minute
this woman laughs like I don't speak for
languages I've got three degrees what is
she trying to say you're not smart it's
okay I think so I do four reasons so
please sir can you help me out I'm
trying to find the husband the kind of
Beast that can handle a woman like me
well well this is well this is another
point right and and I'm only answering
generally right because this is the
first time I've met all of you ladies
you've all been very polite to me you've
all been very nice I'm just talking
generally
and I'm going to answer it based on your
last sentence your last sentence was
handle a woman like me let's let's look
at the average man's life like I just
discussed earlier how difficult it is
how competitive he has to be and how
many problems he has to fix do you think
he wants to handle any woman okay so
like the idea of any degree of problem
it's the straw that breaks the camel's
back like the the point of the point of
having a woman as a man for me at least
is for her to be my peace and quiet I
have my life is stress you see me I'm
rolling around with [ __ ] security
teams and I got problems and they're
after me and I I'm when I come home to
my chick the last thing I want to do is
have to handle anything I want to just
sit the [ __ ] down and her make me happy
she used to be my positive energy she's
my sunshine in the rainstorm so you're
talking about I can handle you I don't
know I can't answer the question exactly
but if you're sitting there constantly
arguing over small points or correcting
him or that he's probably thinking this
is a battle I don't have the energy to
for another fight okay so now let me add
extra context what I mean as well so
obviously submission is something that
people talk about a lot for me I'm a
logical person I believe and I submit
with logic I don't submit by default
because there's a level of respect that
I believe I need to have yes to be able
to submit obviously you know that I go
around and I disrespect old men and
everything but I find that my level of
thought process a lot of the times
um
it makes a heart note so I don't I know
what you're trying to say yeah I think
you know but you need to find a man you
truly respect to submit to him and I
completely respect that and that's the
same with that's the same with 99 of
women like you you're never going to
submit to a man you don't respect and
and respect is ultimately important
because you're not going to sleep with a
man you don't respect you're not gonna
be attracted to a man you don't respect
respect is the bottom line of it and the
man has a job to do he has a duty to do
to be worthy of respect but this all
goes back into a very interesting point
some of the points I've kind of
mentioned earlier if I was a woman if I
was a chick the chance of me ending up
in a relationship with a man I don't
respect is zero percent I don't
understand how you girls end up well I
do understand how you girls end up here
you end up here because of feminism
promise QE promises that running around
taking dick is fine dumb [ __ ] stupid
decisions I'm independent so it doesn't
matter he's a dummy bunch of garbage
when you should be waking up going you
know what I'm going to be extremely
selective and I'm going to take my time
and be very very smart because you're
the gatekeeper by the time you're in a
relationship with somebody you should
have immense respect for that man
absolute immense respect you shouldn't
be able to get there any other way the
only reason you've got there is because
you've been tricked by society and lied
to and told a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ]
so so you're talking about submission
and respect yeah it'll come when you
meet the right man naturally and this is
another point I make because I have a
lot of men message me I trust guys
please understand the most Googled man
on the planet I have the hundred
thousand emails a day thank you for and
I get dudes email me how do I get my
woman to submit and I don't reply to it
I can't reply to all the emails but I if
I ever read them I'm like bro you're a
[ __ ] dork why would she reply to you
why would she submit to you you're a
[ __ ] nerd that's the truth I'm not
out here saying submit to all men men
are the boss I'm saying listen there's
Natural Balance in the universe when you
meet a g I've never had a truck I've
never had trouble with a woman obeying
me she just wants to it's natural for
our Dynamic if she didn't want to obey
me we wouldn't even get to the point of
a relationship if she didn't feel like
she wanted to listen to me we would have
never got to where we want to get it
just doesn't work that [ __ ] only happens
when the females [ __ ] giving up sex
too easy and the dude's just picking up
easy [ __ ] and they end up in some
[ __ ] relationship they don't even
like each other that's dumb [ __ ] that's
dumb [ __ ] right but I don't have any of
these problems in my life and if you're
a dude at home and you're watching this
and you go oh my woman to submit and she
doesn't guess what she doesn't respect
you and guess whose fault that is a lot
of the time your fault that is your
fault as a man
it is yes no no it is yes you guys need
to damn here tell him about blaming men
and women because everyone has a problem
but but then there's also men who are
worthy of respect to women refuse to
respect because of society
there's two sides to it right but a lot
of it is if you're a capable enough man
and you're brilliant enough then the
female has no choice but it's very
interesting this goes back into a point
I made earlier about how important it is
for us men to find women who we don't
believe have had a lot of life
experience and look like they are
because I got attacked I'm gonna make
this point right now I got attacked when
the Matrix attacked me and [ __ ] lied
about me they said that men are
interested in women who are younger
because they're more programmable and
that they're trying to make out that I'm
making out that men are out here trying
to get women and [ __ ] do bad things
to them no what I'm saying is if you
find a woman who's younger and do less
things less trauma less relationships
less headache she's lived less life your
ideals if you ask any woman who loves
her man what's your favorite song his
favorite song who do you vote for who he
votes for what's your favorite car his
car that's how what happens when a woman
loves a man and that makes the man feel
good right if she's been through too
much [ __ ] then that's a lot harder to
pull off so that that that that that
that link is very important for men and
women but um so yeah the Matrix attacked
me with that but it's very very
interesting you have to understand all
these small subdynamics and why things
are happening and why the world is the
way it is and the Baseline of it is is
that everything's [ __ ] men aren't
acting like men and women are acting
like women and it's all messed up oh
yeah so what about like your own
autonomy and like just like you can your
favorite card's your favorite car my
favorite car is my favorite car like why
does it have two okay I guess that's
where I'm because yeah why does it have
to be like that oh yeah and that's a
good point right I understand that
completely but I'll give you an example
I'll talk from personal experience
because it makes it easy for me I have a
bunch of cars I love cars I have 32 cars
my favorite car's X I pick up a chick
this is my uh what's your favorite car
this one I like that one I'm like all
right cool whatever no big deal but
variableness is ultra attractive it
depends what the woman wants to do right
if I was a woman and let's say let's say
I'm let's say I'm 22 years old and I
meet a billionaire and it's my goal to
marry this man and I go to his house and
I say wow you have so many cards what's
your favorite car this one really I
thought that one too it looks so good
why that one because this is this oh
really okay I'll try and remember that
that's how you get the dude right you
don't get the dude by going well that
one is a better color you're a [ __ ]
dude it's it's it may be small things it
may be tiny things but men are Ultra
interested in things like agreeableness
so Ultra interested in the idea of a
woman absorbing Our World Views we're
Ultra interested we are that's what
we're looking away from the woman wait
what if you say she doesn't like the car
no no no why should she agree
why do you want to be with someone
who they are can I say oh I love you
this is my favorite
is quite nice you know actually now that
I'm looking at it it's quite good but I
like this one but I like that one as
well
men don't want a girl that's nagging on
them for the smallest things it's like
why are you giving a guy
that's not lagging though he's saying
he's saying oh what color do you like
why does she have to say his car right
she likes a difference
I'm talking about I am talking about how
as a female to be as attractive as
possible to men now I'm not saying you
can't get a man if you say another car
I'm saying how do you be as ATT
attractive as possible because you're
all about it because you also don't
understand how men think it's different
if you come to my house and choose to
like another one of my cars but what if
I only have one car and now you say well
no I pick up my BMW oh yeah it's nice I
prefer Mercedes you know what man thinks
second you say that who picked you up in
a Merc that's the first thing that goes
to his [ __ ] mind who how do you know
about Mercedes what if you can buy your
own Mercedes that's not what crosses the
man's mind I'm telling you how men think
but then that's why
I'm really happy for you I'm really
happy for your car but the average woman
I'm saying what but the whole point is
that what percent of women even earn
that much it's not a high percentage so
when a guy hears them wait wait wait
when a guy hears that you've been in
this car and that car and that car his
automatic assumption is that you're an
average girl not foolishness and that
and that you've been with a bunch of
guys to get to that point I I've had a
lot of experiences because of my dad
because my dad's very successful but
I've been in situations where I've said
like oh I did this I did this I did this
and they think it's with a guy but it's
with my dad because because most guys
assume that you were an average person
that's demeanor
looking at a balance of probabilities if
I if I meet an average guy I assume he
makes average money I I think it's just
amazing
wait it's based on a balance of
probabilities and as you say something
but it's all about making a man feel
like he everybody says oh he's a top G
but it's like if your man put up a light
fitting
and you're standing watching the part of
the light fitting are you doing Alva
you're they're watching a man put a
light fitting what would you say while
he's putting it up and how would you
react I'd be like you're probably doing
it wrong but I'll let you finish
all right then but hang in a minute and
how would you act if your man
thank you baby okay well I'll be like
see the thing is no just answer the
question just answer the question what
would you say after your mum was putting
up the light fitting I'm just asking
questions
thanks for putting up the like button I
appreciate you my man put up a light for
me and I was like wow he got it all out
it was all in boxes he got his toolbox
he was up there in the ladder whatever
you want me to hand you I was like oh my
God you're stripping Myers
oh my God then he said oh when it
finished I was like it works that's what
he's talking about I agree that is what
he's talking about when he's talking
about the car he's not saying you can
get your own car he's saying make the
man feel like he's doing something make
him feel appreciated like act like a
child
you know and that's what he's saying
he's not saying that oh yeah you don't
like that car it's like my man got a car
it's like oh my God it's got to hit your
seats
I
think I I like to make my mind when my
mom dresses up I'm like girl you look so
fine like I like to make my mom feel
good but he has to do that to me as well
listen right he has to offer me that
song to Mr Tate right say about I never
for instance there's an artist that I
like my man likes it too
covert had just sort of like finished I
got two free tickets to go to the to go
my man said to me you're not going what
would you do
I'm going what would you do uh why why
am I not going it doesn't matter he said
to you because that's just illogical
submission
no but the whole the whole point is you
pick someone that you respect enough to
trust his judgment even because even
when you disagree I want to I want to
fight I don't agree with it
just because you're in a relationship
wait wait wait we need one at a time why
would you think it's something stupid or
whatever you trust a man enough to be
with him you trust the man enough to
sleep with him so why won't you trusted
opinion why does he have to give the
everyone say to my man like if I say to
my man don't do this the first thing is
you're thinking not she's telling what
to do there must be a reason behind it
why she's telling me not to do because
she trusts me I did not go I had two
free tickets I did not go wait wait wait
Auntie you asked me a question I'll tell
you why because the same way a man wants
that sort of validation a woman wants
Assurance I don't want to just blindly
do everything all the time especially
sometimes
the point she's making is twofold and
it's extremely important because a lot
of women talk about being submissive but
they're submissive when it suits them
that's not submission so she wanted to
go to the concert he said no she trusts
him as a man she didn't go absolute
respect for that that's exactly what my
woman would have done exactly the same
thing women go I'm submissive you're
submissive when he's buying you [ __ ] in
bed and you're submissive but the second
he says something you don't like you
instantly turn off the submission run
your [ __ ] mouth that's not submissive
that's manipulation that's [ __ ] so
that's the first thing the second thing
is responsibility in a thorough you're
linked and if as a man if I'm going to
be responsible for a woman I need a
degree of authority over her this is the
reality of it if I'm going to be
responsible for paying your bills or
responsible for your personal safety and
responsible for your personal
development responsible for fixing the
life fitting and responsible for
everything that I'm supposed to do as a
man I need a degree of authority to
sometimes come along and say XYZ and be
obeyed if I'm going to have a ship if
you have a ship the reason the captain
has to go down with the ship is because
he is responsible for everything that
happens on that ship and because of that
he has Authority if he yells at the
Shipmates and they all ignore him then
he can't be considered responsible for
the problems on the ship which means he
doesn't have to die with it if you want
a man invested in a relationship he
needs to be responsible for you but he
needs authority over you and you know
what the smartest thing you do as a
woman is sit and go you know what go
into this concert is two hours but this
is gonna piss him off and his splinter
in his mind for years this is really
worth it now I'm not saying let some man
abuse you let some man treat a [ __ ] but
if you have a good man who's good to you
99 of the time and he comes along and he
really cares about something you should
give him that Grace and give him that
you know what he's the man he said it
boom done because if something happened
to you at that concert if your bag was
snatched if you got [ __ ] robbed if
someone tried to punch you if someone
grabbed you who would you call
the police not police the police you
call him Senor Andrew Mr Tate King
Master supreme leader of everything the
universe The Matrix and all of that no I
just say this as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible